he went on Fox and he was talking about
calling out both Trump and Biden when it
came to the lockdowns and then what
happened to the country economically
after that
I'd like either President Biden or
president Trump
explain the lockdowns to us that was a
16 trillion dollar mistake we shifted
four trillion dollars in wealth from the
middle class in this country to the
super rich this new aristocracy of
billionaires
a lockdown has created a billionaire a
day 500 new billionaires and the people
who came into the lockdown with a
billion dollars
increase their wealth by 30 percent we
had you know 41 percent of black owned
businesses will never reopen some of
those businesses had two or three
generations of Sweat Equity of currency
and um we closed 3.3 million businesses
without due process without judge
compensation the White House both white
houses were collaborating with Amazon
and with the other social media sites to
shut down their competitors Amazon got
to shut down 3.3 million competitors and
we got it two-year Less in the entire
public and out of you know do our
shopping on Amazon and those businesses
those retail businesses with the heart
and soul
of the middle class and our democracy
are now shut down
isn't that refreshing like seeing an
actual Democrat who I may have some dis
disagreements with which would be
absolutely just fine and it would be
great to talk about them truly but a
Democrat not talking down to his
constituents right he's saying Biden
screwed up he's saying Trump screwed up
but he's saying hard truths that it's
the Democrats really who are the ones
that have to think about the covid stuff
more than Republicans like just listen
to Bill Maher what's Bill Maher saying
Hey I want to go out on the road and
tour of course he's saying this you know
this is a year and a half ago or so but
it still to some extent happening right
now uh I want to go out on the road and
tour and people aren't showing up in
blue States right we can't tour in blue
States because people won't come and
that's really what RFK is saying right
there like the the Democrat machine has
scared people to the point that again
they believe in all of these crazy
things you know I think it's worth
mentioning because it's come up a few
times and I see comments about it uh
that RFK actually has a condition it's a
medical condition called called
spasmodic
and that's why his voice has that sort
of there's some gravel in his voice and
it's a little uh inconsistent or
something I know a lot of people have
asked about that I don't know much more
about the condition itself but I think
it is worth mentioning
foreign
[Music]